les autoroutes sans bouchons des
centre-villes presque déserts des
commerces et des usines fermées
l'économie tourne au ralenti la
pollution de l'air diminue c'est certain
qu'une crise sanitaire de cette ampleur
leur réduit drastiquement les
déplacements des gens la productivité
des industries donc par le fait même ça
réduit ici la consommation pétrole et
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
avec cette crise les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre au canada vont diminuer
de façon significative selon cet expert
membre du gie est ça va beaucoup
dépendre j.dray des mesures que veut
imposer le gouvernement canadien
on voit déjà les premières d'entre elles
notamment la fermeture de la frontière
avec les etats-unis une baisse très
importante du nombre de vols
j magique vraisemblablement on pourrait
être dans une baisse de l'ordre de 15 à
20 % à mon avis pour le canada
de plus que la crise sévit la pollution
de l'air diminue dans les pays les plus
touchés enchaîné en italie les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre ont baissé
d'environ 25% et les effets sur
l'environnement ont été bénéfiques selon
cet écologiste on a vu aussi mais un
retour de certains animaux dans les
régions urbaines
une clarification de l'eau dans les
canaux de venise des effets bénéfiques
pour l'environnement mais à quel prix
les écologistes craignent qu'une fois la
crise terminée l'environnement passent
au second plan quand les gouvernements
voudront relancer l'économie une des
craintes majeures qu'on a c'est
clairement que les plans de relance
économique comme on a vu lors de la
crise économique de 2009 où il y à des
injections massives de fonds dans des
secteurs polluants et qui font en sorte
que l'on verra une augmentation de la
pollution des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre pour les environnementalistes
cette crise sanitaire pourrait être
l'opportunité pour le canada car tout
sera terminé de lancer une véritable
transition écologique
ici jean philippe robien à radio canada
montréal